zayıf etkileşimler kısmını görmüştük
zayıf etkileşimleri katılarda
kullanacağız demiştim katıların
özelliklerinden falan bahsedeceğim
katıların türlerinden bahsedeceğim ve
örnekler vermeye çalışacağım elimden
geldiğince elimde olduklarıyla Tabii ki
onu verebileceğim burada güzel şeylerden
bahsedeceğiz katılar önemlidir buradan
soru gelebilir sınavlarda da özellikle
bu kısımdan çok güzel sorular
gelmektedir O zaman vakit kaybetmiyoruz
hazırsan başlayalım şimdi katılar
dediğimizde önce özelliklerinden
bahsedelim katıda tanecikler şöyle
birbirlerine çok yakın oldukları için şu
bu şekilde tanecikler birbirlerine çok
yakın oldukları için aralarında çekim
kuvveti fazla Bundan dolayı katılar
sadece titreşim hareketi yapar e katıda
tanecikler birbirlerine çok yakın
oldukları için katıların belirli bir
şekli ve hacmi vardır mesela sıvıda
belirli bir şekil yoktur ama belirli bir
hacim vardır konulduğu kabın şeklini
almaktadır gazlarda ise belirli bir
şekil ve hacim yoktur bulunduğu kabın
tamamını doldurmaktadır Öyle bir
özellikleri vardır burada katılarda
belirli bir şekilde vardır belirli bir
hacim de var vardır diyoruz başka neyden
bahsediyoruz burada tanecikler arası
boşluk çok azdır Bundan dolayı
tanecikler arası çekim gücü en fazladır
maddenin diğer hallerine göre söylüyoruz
Tabii ki bunu bak sığdıramam şım dur bak
söylemiyorsunuz da Ha h şöyle biraz bu
tarafa alalım Bir de tabii ki şunu
söylememiz lazım katılar
sıkıştırılamaz diyoruz tamam mı katı
tanecikleri sıkıştırılamaz Şöyle
örneklendir mesela mesela bak elimde bir
tane kaya tuzu yapısı var şöyle Ben bunu
istediğim kadar sıkıştırın bu ne
olacaktır sıkışmayı yani istediğim kadar
baskı uygulayım bu sıkışmayı dostum
devam edelim şimdi katıların türleri
vardır katıları Biz önce ikiye
ayırıyoruz Amorf katılar ve kristal
katılar şeklinde ikiye ayırıyoruz Amorf
katıları şimdi söyleyeceğim kristal katı
türlerimiz nedir iyonik katılar yani
iyonik bağlı yapıların olduğu katılar
kovalent katılar var şurada yapısında
kovalent Bağlar Var kovalent a örgüsü
var böyle moleküler katılar var ki
onlarda da tanecikler arasında Yani
şöyle söyleyeyim o orada Önemli olan
moleküller arası Bağları yani zayıf
etkileşimlerden bahsedeceğiz ve metalik
katılar var Orada da metalik bağ
olduğundan bahsedeceğiz Dostum şimdi
Amorf katıyla devam edelim istersen
Amorf katı bak Amorf şekilsiz böyle bir
anlama gelmektedir Normalde katıda
tanecikler belirli bir düzene sahiptir
ama Amorf katılarda tanecikler belirli
bir düzene sahip değildir yani
tanecikler Gelişi güzel istiflenmiş
böyle bir ifade kullanılmaktadır O
yüzden belirli bir geometrik şekli
olmayan katılara Biz Amorf katı ismini
veriyoruz Tabii ki bunlar da katı oldu
için sert ve sıkıştırılamazlar bu
özellikler değişmiyor zaten örnek olarak
da en çok karşına çıkacak örnekler şöyle
yaklaşıyorum cam lastik plastik kauçuk
tereyağı gibi örneklerdir Bunlar en
fazla karşına çıkacak örneklerdir
bunların şöyle bir özelliği vardır Amorf
katıların belirli bir erime noktaları
yoktur ısıttığın önce yumuşamaya
başlarlar İşte o yumuşamaya başladığı
sıcaklığa Biz camsı geçiş sıcaklığı
ismini veriyoruz Bunu sana şöyle bir
örnekle göstereyim yaklaşım elimde şöyle
bir tane plastik par parçası var şöyle
dur Heh zoomlu plastik parçası var Ben
bunu şöyle ısıtmaya başladığımda şu
şekilde ısıtmaya başladığımda dur alttan
da birazcık daha ısıtacağım üstten de
birazcık daha ısıtacağım şimdi yakmam
gayret ediyorum o yüzden şimdi
yumuşamaya başladı bu şöyle Bak görüyor
musun hemen yumuşadı İşte bu şeylerin
Amorf katıların böyle bir özelliği
vardır yani ne yapıyor bir önce
yumuşuyor böyle ilk başta ısıttığın önce
yumuşuyor Camda da böyle bir durum söz
konusudur İşte buna biz bu
yere ne diyoruz biz camsı geçiş
sıcaklığı diyoruz Amorf katılarda böyle
bir durum söz konusu Amorf katılar sert
olma dışındaki birçok özelliğiyle
Aslında sıvılara benzemektedir şöyle bir
şey vardır Hatta uzun süre cam için sıvı
demişlerdi çok uzun sürede akışkanlık
gösteren bir sıvı demişlerdi Hayır daha
sonra Amorf katı olarak güncellendi
tabii ki ama özellik olarak sıvıya
benzemektedir bazı özellikleri onu da
söylemiş olalım işte Bak burada
örneklerimiz var kavuç var tereyağı
plastik ne var bur işte cam var burada
işte nedir bunlar işte Amorf katı
örneklerimiz deir dostum kristal katı
dediğimizde ise bunların belirli bir
geometrik düzeni vardır yani tanecikler
arasında belirli bir geometrik düzen
vardır düzenli şekilde istiflenmiş
derdir buna kristal katılar diyoruz
birazdan örneklerini göstereceğim zaten
kristal katılar sert ve
sıkıştırılamazlar günlük hayatta
karşımıza çıkan birçok şey bu şekilde
işte yani kristal katıdır örneklerini
birazdan göstereceğim Mesela bak grafit
kalemin ucu glikoz yani şeker
diyebilirsin buna başka Demir tuz iyot
elma mas pek karşımıza çıkmıyor ama
demek bazısının çıkıyormuş bunu yazan
herhalde zengin değil mi bu ifadeyi
yazan zengin bir Yok canım değil o kadar
da zengin değil değil mi çinko Demir
mesela bunu da örnek olarak verebilirim
şimdi Bak burada da işte gösteriyor iyot
dediğimiz böyle bir yapı bu kovalent
katı ne Pardon kovalent değil moleküler
katı olarak söyleyeceğiz ı2 molekülünden
oluşuyor glikoz mesela C6 h12 o6 bunun
Tabii ki C12 h22 o1 dediğimiz bir yapısı
da var aslında bu şeker dediğimiz Yapı
budur mesela o da kristal katıyor
örnektir mesela Demir başka grafit
karbondan oluşuyor Bunlar bazı kristal
katı örnekleri Bak ne diyor maddenin
katı hali ile ilgili aşağıdakilerden
hangisi yanlıştır diye soruyor
baktığımızda diyor ki sıkıştırılamazlar
evet doğru Maddenin en düzensiz halidir
yanlış katı maddenin en düzenli halidir
Hatta şöyle göstereyim katı sıvı gaz
diye ifade ediyoruz katıdan gaza doğru
düzensizlik artar gazdan katıya doğru
düzenlilik artar Maddenin en düzenli
hali katıdır Burada en düzensiz demiş o
yüzden yanlıştır buna Amorf katı da
dahil onu da söylemiş olayım yani
düzenli haldir sıvı ve gaza göre daha
düzenlidir başka tanecikler arası
etkileşimlerin en yüksek olduğu durumdur
Evet katıya doğru gittikçe tanecikler
arası etkileşim artar Çünkü tanecikler
birbirlerine yaklaşıyorlar başka bir
kısmı Amorf yapılı bir kısmı kristal
yapılı olabilir Evet doğrudur
tanecikleri titreşim hareketi yapar Evet
doğrudur cevap Ne oldu B seçeneği burada
bir soru var Bak bu ne çinko çinko metal
Tamam yazdık yanına çinko diye bu da
plastik plastik neydi Amorf katıydı
Amorf katı çinko ise krist kristal bir
katı kristal metalik kristal katı onu da
şöyle yazmış olalım diyor ki Yukarıdaki
maddelerle ilgili her ikisi için de
doğrudur belirli bir geometrik şekli
vardır dediği çinko için doğru ama kim
için yanlış bu plastik için yanlış O
yüzden bu gitti serttir ikisi için de
doğru Bunlar ikisi de katı olduğu için
sıkıştırılamazlar ikisi için de doğru
cevap D seçeneği olacak Dostum şimdi
kristal katılardan bahsedelim önce
iyonik kristalden bahsedelim istersen
neydi iyonik kristal moleküler kristal
kovalent kristal ve ne vardı metalik
kristalim vardı iyonik kristal anyon ve
katyonların elektrostatik çekim
Kuvvetleri ile bir arada durduğu
katılardır yani iyonik bağlı katılardır
Aslında iyonik kristal dediğimiz şey
iyonik bağlı katılardır burada katıyı
oluşturan yapılar neydi iyonların
belirli bir geometrik düzenle
oluşturduğu ne vardı birim hücreler
vardı değil mi birim hücre yapısındadır
demiştik Burada bazı şeyler vermiş örnek
sofra tuzu mesela iyonik bağlı iyonik
bağlı bileşiklerin kat hali iyonik katı
olarak geçmekte bu kadar basit veya dedi
ki iyonik katılarda ya da iyonik
kristallerde hangi etkileşim vardır
İyonik bağ vardır ne olacak yani burada
da bak örgü yapısında olduğunu
gösteriyor sodyum klorürün yapısı mesela
burada farklı tuzların yapılarını da
burada gösteriyor işte burada farklı
farklı neler var tuzlar var yani iyonik
kristaller örnek olarak gösterilmiş
burada bir genelleme yapmış diyor ki
iyonik katılarda genellikle anyonlar
katyonlardan daha büyüktür yani çünkü
elektron aldığı için anyonun çapı
artıyordu ne oluyordu e diğeri de şeyde
katyon oluşturan ne yapıyordu elektron
verdiği için çapı küçülüyordu Bu nedenle
iyonik katılarda anyonların oluşturduğu
boşluklara katyonlar girmektedir diye
bir ifade kullanıyor çok önemli mi Yani
bazen sorulabilir bilmekte fayda var en
etkin kuvvet Tabii ki ne olacaktır
İyonik bağ olacaktır e burada Bundan
dolayı İyonik bağ çok kuvvetli bir bağ
olduğu için katılar ne olacaktır serttir
ve erime ve kaynama noktaları yüksektir
yani iyonik katıların erime ve kaynama
noktaları yüksek bunu bilmek lazım Ve
tabii ki iyonik bağlı katılar ki ya bir
dakika iyonik bağlı katıya niye örnek
göstermiyorum dur Heh şöyle yaklaşım
sana bak şöyle bu kaya tuzu şöyle büyük
bir kaya tuzu bu sodyum klorür Bunun
içerisinde şuralarda falan da E şu an
net görebiliyor musun bilmiyorum ama
şurada Normalde işte sodyum klorürün
oluşturduğu bu deminki o kübik Yapı
mevcut İşte bu iyonik bir katı iyonik
Bir kristal sodyum klorür Yani bu işte
sofra tuzu Ama bu kaya tuzu halinde
Hatta
bakayım ve bayağı tuzlu Neyse Yani evet
tuz bu işte ama güzelmiş arada bunu yok
neyse kullanmayın boş Heh devam edelim
Bu iyonik katılar katı halde elektriği
iletmezler ama sıvı hali veya sulu
çözelti hali elektriği iletir Çünkü
ortama iyon bırakmaktadır Bu da önemli
bir bilgidir burada Mesela sodyum klorür
katısın burada şey daldırdığı bak şöyle
Yaklaştır elektrik sistemini
daldırılan mıyor ama tuzlu su yaptığında
ortamda sodyum artı iyonları ve Klor
eksi iyonları olduğu için elektrik akımı
iletiliyor ve lamba yanmaya başlıyor
dostum buraya bakalım Diyor ki
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi artı ve eksi
yüklü iyonlar arasında elektrostatik
çekim sonucunda meydana gelmiştir artı
eksi yüklü yani anyon ve katyon arasında
elektrostatik çekim yani bana iyonik
bağlı hangisi iyonik bağlıdır diye
soruyor bakıyoruz ametal ametal bu
kovalent bağlı gitti Metal ametal Evet
burada ne oluyordu anyon ve katyon
oluşturuyordu bu sofra tuzundan
bahsediyor yani iyonik bağlı bir yapı bu
olacaktır bu metal burada katyon oluş
Yani şöyle söyleyeyim Ne vardı işte bir
elektron Denizi içerisinde katyonlar
vardı E ne oldu burada şey yok eksi
yüklü iyon yok elektron var Bundan
dolayı yani metalik bağlı bir yapıdan
bahsediyoruz Bu da gitti H2 kovalent
bağlı bir yapı H2O kovalent bağlı bir
yapı iyonik bağlığı sorduğu için cevabım
B seçeneği burada diyor ki saf x katısı
kalsiyum + 2 ve Klor -1 iyonlarını
oluşturmaktaydı o zaman bunun formülünü
bulursun ne olacaktır bu + 2 bu -1
olduğu için şundan iki tane alırsan artı
ve eksi sayısı eşitlenir ccl2 tuzundan
bahsediyor Aslında Kalsiyum klorür
kısıdı bu Bakalım iyonik bağlı kalsiyum
klorik kısıdı doğru e birim hücrelerden
oluşan bir kristal yapıya sahiptir Evet
doğru iyonik bağlı bileşikler birim
hücrelerden oluşuyordu erime ve kaynama
noktaları iyonik bağlılar yüksekti düşük
demiş gitti cevap 1 ve 2 C seçeneği
olacak moleküler katılara gelelim
istersen bir de moleküler katılar ya da
moleküler kristaller dediğimizde katıyı
oluşturan birimler moleküldür ve katı
halde olması lazım Mesela molekül olan
H2O diyeceksin ki hocam bunun katı hali
e buz değil mi karbondioksit Bu bir
molekül katı hali Buna da kuru buz
diyoruz kuru buz bu Dondurma falan
aldığında yanında şey oluyor böyle tüten
bir şey oluyor veya deneylerde falan da
yapanlar oluyor havuzu komple bununla
dolduran oluyor mesela etraf böyle duman
oluyor e karbondioksitin katı hali bu da
bir moleküler katı örneğidir ya Veya
şeker Bizim bildiğimiz şeker mesela aynı
şekilde moleküler bir katıdır iyot
katısı mesela aynı şekilde bu nedir
moleküler bir katıdır şimdi örneğim var
mı bakıyorum bakıyorum etrafımda Aha
varmış Onu da göstereyim şöyle hemen Heh
şöyle getireyim bu mesela bak içerisinde
dur He şöyle netle bakayım içerisinde
buz var var Mesela bu ne yapıyor işte
H2O katı hali öyle göstermiş olayım bu
şey bu göz altları için falan Böyle
güzel oluyor biliyor musun bayağı bir
şey yani Kendime dikkat ederim yok ya
kullandığım Yok şeyde dolapta duruyor
İşte böyle arada bir göstermek için
kullanıyorum He Naftalin Mesela bu
lobola falan koyuyorlar ya beyaz böyle
top top şeklinde Naftalin aynı şekilde
bu da kovalent Pardon kovalent değil
moleküler bir katıdır Başka ne ve örneği
verebiliriz başka Ya bunlar yeterli
Aslında Burada şu vardır bak CO2 polar
bir yapıdır bundan dolayı tanecikler
arasında dipol dipol etkileşimi vardır
iyot var mesela veya karbondioksit veya
Naftalin bak cvan oluşan apolar bir
yapıdan bahsediyoruz şöyle apolar Yapı
iyot apolar karbondioksit apoları
bunların tanecikleri arasında ne olacak
o zaman London etkileşimi olacak veya
buz değil mi veya glikoz başka nh3 HF
bunların kat hali olsaydı Bunlarda da
Hidrojen bağı olacaktı Ha demek ki ben
bir şey anlamış oldum buradan moleküler
katılarda ne oluyormuş tanecikler
arasında neler olabilir irmiş dipol
dipol olabilirmiş Başka ne olabilirmiş
London olabilirmiş başka Hidrojen bağı
olabilirmiş yani moleküler katılarda
tanecikler arasında moleküler Bağlar
varmış yani zayıf etkileşimler varmış Bu
da önemli bir bilgidir ve şöyle bir şey
var tabii ki moleküller arasındaki
etkileşimler İyonik ve kovalent bağdan
daha zayıf olduğu için erime ve kaynama
noktaları İyonik katılardan ve kovalent
katılardan genel olarak daha düşüktür
bunu bilmekte fayda var bu önemlidir
Çünkü burada ne diyor Heh burada bak
Parafin yani neye örnek verebiliriz
parafine muma örnek verebiliriz mesela
Naftalin gibi bazı moleküller yumuşaktır
Ama onun dışındakilerin çoğu sert yapıya
sahiptir erime ve kaynama noktaları
düşüktür Çünkü zayıf etkileşimler burada
etkili diğerlerinde güçlü etkileşimler
vardı E tabii ki bunlar moleküler yapılı
oldukları için Elektrik akımını
iletmezler ortamda iyon yok çünkü burada
bazı örnekler vermiş Mesela kırmızı
fosforu örnek vermiş başka neyi örnek
vermiş bu rombik kükürt müydü yok
monoklin kükürt Mesela kükürtün bir türü
çok önemli değil glikoz buz mesela başka
Naftalin kuru buz gibi örnekler şöyle
yazalım kuru buz örneklerini verebiliriz
Burada da işte kırmızı fosforu göstermiş
kükürtü göstermiş buzu vermiş Naftalin
İşte bu lavabolara falan koyuyorlar ya
onu örnek olarak göstermiş Bunlar
moleküler katılar dostum Bak ne diyor
örnekte moleküler katılarla ilgili
olarak hangileri doğrudur tüm
örneklerinde kristali bir arada tutan
kuvvetler dipol dipol tüm örneklerinde
mi hayır Mesela H2O da temel kuvvet
orada Etkin olan kuvvet hidrojen bağıdır
Tamam dipol dipol olanlar var ama
hepsinde dipol dipol Hayır diyemezsin
veya kurub buzda sadece London dur o
yüzden bu gitti Isı ve elektriği
iletmezler Evet doğru bir ifade erime ve
kaynama noktaları genel olarak düşüktür
doğru bir ifade cevap da D seçeneği
gelelim kovalent katılara kovalent
katılar dediğimizde tanecikleri
arasındaki etkileşim türü kovalent
bağdır burada güçlü kovalent bağlarla
tanecikler bir arada bulunmaktadır bunu
birazdan örneklendir zaten şöyle bir şey
var burada şeyler atomlar veya işte o
yapılar birbirlerine kovalent bağlarla
bağlı oluyor ve bir ağ örgüsü
oluşturuyor bu oluşturduğu ağ örgüsü çok
sağlam bir yapıya sahip olduğu için
Mesela özellikle karbona örnek
verebiliriz ki bu iki tane çok önemli
kovalent katı meydana getiriyor birisi
Elmas diğeri de grafit mesela erime ve
kaynama noktası elmasın çok çok
yüksektir Gerçekten sağlam bir yapıya
sahiptir işte burada gösteriyor bak
elmasın yapısı Bir karbon dört farklı
karbona bağlanıyor görüyor musun diğer
karbon aynı şekilde dört farklı karbona
bağlıyor böyle bir yapı oluşturuyor ağ
örgüsü oluşturuyor çok güçlü bir yapı
oluşuyor Bu O yüzden elmaslar mesela çok
serttir çok sağlamdır mesela elmasla
camı kesebilirsin yani Elmas uçlu
matkaplar var mesela duvarı delebilirsin
tabii her elmas böyle görünmüyor Bu saf
elmaslardan bahsediyoruz Ama onun
dışındakiler Mesela bu matkap uçlarında
kullanılanlar daha farklı tabii ki
grafit de mesela şöyledir grafit Bir tık
daha yumuşaktır Tabii ki elmasa göre
orada da kovalent bir örgü var a örgüsü
var Sonra aralarında da böyle bir
etkileşim var bunun kaynama noktası
erime noktası Tabii ki elmasa göre daha
düşük ama E tabii ki şey var yani
kovalent katılar erime ve kaynama
noktaları yüksek yapılardır bir tek
grafitini birazcık daha düşüktür
Normalde elektrik akımıyla iletmezler
kovalent katılar ama grafit elektriği
iletmektedir önemli bir bilgidir onu da
söylememiz de fayda var erime ve kaynama
noktası yazıyor işte grafit Elmas gibi
karbon atomlarının oluşmasına rağmen
erime ve kaynama noktası elmastan
düşüktür ve elmastan daha yumuşaktır bu
önemli bir bilgidir bunu bilmek lazım
Peki başka kovalent katı yok mu Tamam
Elmas grafit Eyvallah Bir de silisyumlu
bileşik var bak silisyumlu bileşikler
görüyor musun silisyumlu bileşikler de
kovalent katıyı örnek olarak verilebilir
sana iki tane kovalent katı örneği
göstermek istiyorum birisi Tabii ki
elması gösteremeyeceği göre Neyi
gösteriyorum şöyle getirdim mesela
grafiti örnek olarak göstereyim bak bu
grafit kalem ucu kalemin ucu grafitten
oluşmaktadır daha yumuşak bir yapıya
sahiptir Bu bir kovalent katıdır mesela
bunu hop yerine koyalım ondan sonra
başka bir örneği göstereceğim O da
mesela kuvars işte silisyum oksit
dediğimiz Yapı şu da kuars dediğimiz
Yapı Bu da silisyum oksit kovalent katı
olarak geçmekte bunun Pembesi de var
mesela şu da pembe kuars olarak
gösterilmekte dur şöyle göstereyim şu da
pembe kuars da şu an tabii çok da belli
olmuyor değil mi Dur bir dakika şöyle
yapayım Bir dakika arka tarafına Bir
zemin
yerleştireceğim ama sonuçta pembe bir
yapıya sahip Bu da ne oluyor işte pembe
kuars kuars da neymiş Nereye koydum lan
h o da neymiş işte işte kovalent katıya
örnek olarak veriliyormuş Demek ki
neymiş kovalent katılar Karbonun
yapıları Elmas grafit Bir de silisyumlu
bileşikler tamam mı dostum Bak ne diyor
burada diyor ki hem bileşik hem de
element örnekleri vardır neyden
bahsediyor kovalent katılardan
bahsediyor Evet element örnekleri
karbondur değil mi Elmas grafit bunu
örnek olarak verebiliriz bileşik
örnekleri de mesela silisyumlu
bileşikler değil mi Bunlar da kovalent
katı örnekli Demek ki kovalent katı ile
ilgili olarak bu doğru kristal yapılıdır
Evet kovalent katılarda kristal katıdır
Doğrudur üçte diyor ki örgü birimlerini
bir arada tutan kuvvetler diyor her
zaman güçlü etkileşimler e kovalent
Bağlar var burada değil mi zaten
kovalent katı da kovalent bağ olması
gerekiyor doğru bir ifade cevabımız e
seçeneği gelelim metalik katılara
metalik katılarda haliyle metal
atomlarını bir arada tutan kuvvet neydi
metalik bağı değil mi yani metalik bağ
ile metal atomları bir araya geldiğinde
oluşan katı metalik katı olarak ifade
edilmektedir belirli bir düzeni vardır
Tabii ki bunların metalik katılarda
Metal katyonları ne yapıyor belirli bir
düzene göre ne yapıyor düzen oluşturuyor
bu elektron Denizi falan vardı ya bu
burada ifade ediyor işte bak metalik
katılarda katyonlar pozitif iyonlar Yani
serbest hareketli elektron Denizi
içerisinde çevrilmiş şekilde bir arada
bulunur yani neydi bu metalik bağ
bulunmaktaydı metalik katılarda Bu kadar
basit yani Uzatmaya gerek yok Bunu başka
neyden bahsederiz işte metalik bağdaki
elektron hareketinden dolayı bazı
özellikler kazanıyor metaller birisi
parlaklık birisi Isı ve elektriği iletme
birisi de tel ve levhe haline
getirilebilen dövülebilir verilebilme
olarak söylenebilir Buna da örnek
göstereyim Bir saniye şöyle yap
yapacağım bak şu parmağımı şöyle
göstereyim bak şu ne şu Gümüş değil mi
İşte şu Gümüş metalik katı Şuradaki
yapısa şu üstündeki Yapı İsa iyonik Bir
kristal Bu neydi şeydi galiba ne
zultanit
taşıyıc kristal olarak söyleyebilirim
burada metal atomları metalik bağ ile
bir arada bulunmakta ve belirli bir
şekil alabilmekte bu Normalde işte
dikdörtgen bir şekildeyken dövüle dövüle
bu şekle Getiriyorlar gelelim buraya
metalik metallerin erime ve kaynama
noktaları yüksek olduğu için metalik
katıların erime ve kaynama noktaları
genel olarak yüksektir Diyebiliriz ama
tabii ki düşük olanları yok mu var
mesela galyum 29.88 derecede erimekte
yani galyum metalini avucunu alıp
sıktığında eritebilir Çünkü vücudun 36,5
derece aşağı yukarı Ne yapıyorsun
eritebilen eritmek istesen 3680 derece
gerekiyor Yani demek ki metalik bağın
gücüne göre ne olmakta bu durum
değişmekte onu söylemek lazım işte
burada bazı metalik katılar örnek vermiş
altın çinko Gümüş bakır başka potasyum
sodyum gibi örnekler vermiş mesela
sodyum yine yumuşak olanlardan bir
tanesi bak göstermiş işte tungsten
metali lambalardaki o şeyler var ya
ampullerdeki o parlaklık veren kısım var
ya Şuradan bahsediyorum şeyde hava almaz
bir ortamda olduğu için elektrik
enerjisini aldığında ve 3600 küsur
derecede eridiği için ne oluyor Isı ve
elektriği rahatlıkla iletebilir ve o
parlaklığı veriyor kopmuyor mesela ama
bir oksijen girse içeriye yani lambada
ufak bir delik olsa anında yanarak gider
mesela burada şey var sodyum var bıçakla
bile kesilebilir diyor bazısı işte
yumuşak olmakta buradaki bir örnek var
bak elektron denizi var elektron
Denizinin ortasında katyonlar var bir
metalik bağdan bahsediyor diyor ki oda
koşullarında bir maddeye ait atomların
atomların arasındaki bağ yapısı yanda
verilmiştir metalik bağdan bahsediyor
bakalım Bununla ilgili olarak hangisi
yanlıştır diyor kendine özgü parlaklığı
vardır metalik bağ olduğu için burada
metalden bahsediyoruz Evet kendine özgü
bir parlaklığı vardır Doğru Elektriği
ileten bir kristal katıdır e metaller
elektriği ilettiği için doğru bir ifade
atomlar arasında sadece zayıf etkileşim
metalik bağ bulunmakta atomlar arasında
e metalik bağ da güçlü bir etkileşim de
yanlış bir ifade diyor ki lityum
elementi olabilir E1 yük alabildiğine
göre lityum da metal olduğuna göre
Olabilir mi Olabilir doğru diyor ki
periyodik sistemde B gruplarında yer
alabilir ya Niye olmasın olabilir + 1
yük alabilen bir B grubu elementi de
olabilir kesin bir yanlışlığı yok bunun
Biz yanlışı bulduk zaten cevabımız C
seçeneği Bak burada bir tablo vermiş
hepsini burada özetlemiş diyor ki iyonik
katı da tanecikler neymiş iyonlar mış
böyle bir düzen var işte birim hücre
yapısı Hatta şöyle üstüne de yazalım
istersen birim hücre yapısına sahiptir
diye zıt yüklü iyon arasındaki
elektrostatik çekim kuvveti Yani bir
arada tutan kuvvet neymiş İyonik bağ
imiş değil mi onu söyleyelim E bu iyonik
bağlı bileşikler olduğu için sert ve
kırılgandır yani vurduğunda
dağılmaktadır erime noktaları yüksektir
iletken değildirler katı halde ama sıvı
sıvı yken ya da sulu çözelti iken
iletkendir bunu söylemek lazım Burada
örnekler vermiş işte iyonik bağlı
bileşikler nacl KF mgo cao mgcl2 daha
birçok örnek verilebilir moleküler katı
dediğimizde ise moleküler katılarda
tanecikleri bir arada tutan kuvvet zayıf
etkileşimlerdir şöyle yazalım zayıf
etkileşimler bunu bir arada tutmakta
nedir bu zayıf etkileşimler dipol dipol
London kuvvetleri ve Hidrojen bağı
şeklinde söyleyebiliriz burada işte
özellikleri neydi genellikle yumuşaktır
erime noktaları diğerlerine göre daha
düşüktür ve iletken değildirler bunları
söyleyebiliriz burada tüm molekülleri
verebilirsin örnek olarak katı haldeki
Mesela işte ı2 S8 p4 C10 h8 yani
Naftalin kuru buz normal buz şeker bu
işte glikoz bu daha doğrusu disakkarit
ya bu ne oluyordu ismi Onu şu an artık
onu şeyler daha iyi bilir Semi Hocam
daha iyi bilir Sonuçta böyle bir yapı
vardır Bunların hepsi moleküler katıya
örnek olarak verilebilir burada kovalent
katı dediğimizde tanecikleri bir arada
tutan kuvvet genel olarak kovalent bağ
olarak ifade edilmektedir serttirler
erime ve kaynama noktaları yüksektir
iletken değildirler ama grafit hariç
Tabii ki grafit iletkendir Burada da
göstermiş elmas ve grafit element
özelliği gösteren ama kovalent katı
olanlar bir de silisyumlu bileşikler
vardı silisyum Karbür silisyum oksit ve
silisyum nitrür dediğimiz yapılar Bunlar
da kovalent katılara örnek burada
metalik katılar dediğimizde ne vardı
yapısında elektronlar ve katyonlar Çünkü
metalik bağ bulunmaktaydı e Bunlar Sert
veya yumuşak olabilmekte erime noktaları
düşük olan da var yüksek olan da var o
metalik bağın gücüne göre değişmekte ve
kesinlikle elektriği
iletmektedir hepsini örnek olarak
verebilirsin çinko sodyum magnezyum
alüminyum demir Kalay bakır gümüş gibi
örnekler verilebilir bakalım örneklerde
ne diyor bak Birincisinde zıt yüklü
iyonlar var görüyor musun Bir küçük bir
büyük burada iyonik bağlı bir yapıdan
bahsediyor iyonik Yapı iyonik katıdan
bahsediyor lityum bromür olabilir
potasyum klorür olabilir lityum florür
olabilir yani iyonik bağlılar
ikincisinde böyle katmanlar var
katmanlar birbirlerine bağlı grafitten
bahsediyor burada grafitinin yapısından
bahsediyor onu çizdik üçüncüsünde Bak
tek cins atom var görüyor musun tek cins
atom bir arada duruyor burada metalik
bağdan bahsedebiliriz var mı var cevabım
Ne oldu C seçeneği oldu burada tabii
aklına şu gelebilir hocam karbonda da
tek şey var tek element var Yani bu
elmas olamaz mı hayır elmasta nasıl bir
yapı vardı Böyle bir a şekli vardı a
gibi örülüdür buradaya istiflenme
şeklinde böyle üst üste istiflenme bu
metalik bağda mevcut Bu soruya bakalım
Diyor ki boş bırakılan yerlere uygun
kelimeleri yazın diyor Bakalım silisyum
oksit silisyumlu bileşik Bu neydi
kovalent katıya örnekti kovalent katı
bakalım şöyle işaretleyelim diyor ki
iyonik kristallerde tekrar eden
birimlere Ne diyorduk Biz birim hücre
diyorduk değil mi birim hücre yapıları
diyorduk başka buraya da yazalım birim
hücre belirgin geometrik şekilleri
olmayan katılara bak belirli geometrik
şekilleri yoksa Amorf katı diyorduk
şöyle Amorf katı çok kötü yazdım ama
neyse hatan aşağıda var cevap Ne oldu a
seçeneği burada diyor ki Aşağıda verilen
maddelerden hangisinin örgü birimlerini
bir arada tutan kuvvetler yanlış
verilmiştir H bu ne potasyum florür
iyonik bağlı bir yapı İyonik bağ bir
arada tutmaktadır Bu Demir Metal metalik
bağ olmalı buraya baktığımızda ne var
karbondioksit Bu neydi apolar yapıydı
Bundan dolayı tanecikleri bir arada
tutan kuvvet London
kuvvetiyle serbest dolaşan elektronlar
bulunmaz serbest dolaşan elektron
metalik bağda bulunmakta Ha o zaman
Çelik metal bakır metal altın metal krom
metal bunlarda metalik bağ var serbest
elektronlar dolanmak da elektron Denizi
içerisinde katyonlar vardı ya o durumdan
bahsediyor ama fosfor ametal didir
Bundan dolayı burada öyle bir durum söz
konusu değildir Cevap O yüzden C
seçeneği diyor ki moleküler kristallerle
ilgili kristal birimler arasında He
moleküler kristallerde kristal birimleri
arasında moleküler kristallerde neler
olması gerekiyordu dipol dipol London ve
Hidrojen bağı olması gerekiyordu
hangileri bulunabilir Hidrojen bağı
London dipol dipol hepsi var Cevap e
seçeneği Aha dolduralım bakalım Diyor ki
Burayı işte katı sınıfını yazın diyor
şöyle yaklaşıyorum birazcık da bu ne
Demir demirse metalik katı metalik katı
S8 Bu bir molekül değil mi moleküler
katı moleküler katı karbondioksit de bir
molekül karbondioksit kurubuz olarak
geçiyordu moleküler katı e H2O buz
olarak geçiyordu Bu da bir molekül
moleküler katı silisyumlu bileşik
dediğim değ imiz anda kovalent katıdan
bahsediyoruz grafit karbon karbon
türevleri de neydi kovalent katıydı onu
da şöyle işaretledikten
ifade ediliyor O2 Bu bir molekül O
yüzden moleküler katı olarak söylüyoruz
bunun katı halinden bahsediyoruz ccl2
Metal ametal iyonik bağlı bir yapıdan
bahsediyoruz iyonik katı olarak söyledik
bunu da Elmas neydi karbon
yapısıyla bileşik kovalent katı altın
metal olduğu için metalik katı olarak
ifade ediyoruz Burada da bazı katılar
vermiş bunların tanecikler arasındaki
etkileşim türünü soruyor Bu bir metalik
katı O yüzden burada metalik bağdan
bahsedebiliriz değil mi burada H2O var
H2O Bir molekül Bu katıyı bir arada
tutan kuvvet hidrojen
bağlarıyla Bir molekül O yüzden
tanecikler arasında dipol dipol
etkileşimi olmaktadır e grafit neydi
kovalent bağlarla birbirine bağlı bir
yapı vardı burada kovalent kristali
olduğu için kovalent bağ olması
gerekiyor e silisyum bileşiği yani
silisyumlu bileşikler kovalent katı
olduğu için kovalent bağ etkiliydi
burada Buraya baktığımızda Gümüş metalik
bağ metal olduğu için metalik bağ
olacaktır burada Şunlara bağ diye yazsam
Heh bakalım nafe metal metal iyonik
bağlı bir yapıdan bahsediyoruz yani
iyonik katı olacak burası Pardon İyonik
bağ olacak burası çok güzel lityum oksit
Metal ametal Bu da iyonik bağlı değil mi
Onu da şöyle işaretledikten
8 c vhan oluşanlar apolarda apolar
olunca tanecikler arasında London
etkileşimi oluyor bu katı bu şekilde
oluşuyor diyebiliriz Dostum Evet
Böylelikle katıları bitirmiş olduk katı
türlerinden bahsettim Amorf katılar
kristal katılar onların detaylarından
bahsettim Aslında zor bir şey yok Amorf
katılarda ne oluyordu Bir camsı geçiş
sıcaklığı vardı Zaten birkaç tane
örneğimiz var cam lastik kavuç plastik
Bir de tereyağından bahsetmiştik kristal
katılarda İsa iyonik katıda İyonik bağ
etkilidir moleküler katıda moleküler
arası etkileşim ler vardı moleküller
arası etkileşimler neydi dipol dipol
Hidrojen bağı ve London kuvvetleri
etkili demiştik sonra kovalent katılarda
ne olacak tanecikler arasında kovalent
Bağlar olacak Orada Önemli olan Detay
karbonlu bileşikler Bir de neydi
silisyumlu bileşiklere dikkat ediyorsun
kovalent katılarda e metalik katılarda
da metalik bağ etkilidir Bu kadar basit
dostum beni dinlediğin için teşekkür
ederim ama kanala abone olmadan
izliyorsan burada üzülürüm Gönül koyarım
kanala abone olarak izlersen Ben içerik
üretmeye devam edeceğim yeni müfredatta
yanındayım Sonuna kadar yanındayım tüm
zedu ailesi olarak yanındayız zaten
bundan dolayı abone olmanı istiyorum
rica ediyorum arada bir zedu ncom a da
bakabilirsin Orada da güzel içerikler
paylaşıyoruz beni dinlediğin için tekrar
teşekkür ediyorum İki fosfor bir asit
kimya Bu kadar basit görüşmek üzere